Welcome to the DesignaKnit 8
video learning series.
In this tutorial,
we'll be working in Original Pattern
Drafting to learn
the basics of this section.
Right now, all of the icons are grayed out
except for a few here because I don't have
any garment shape in my workspace shades.
The easiest way to get used to using this
section is to open a garment shape
from the Standard Garment
Styling section first.
Let's go there and I'm going
to say open up a child's top.
Okay.
And I have a child's top ready to knit.
We can go right back to original pattern
drafting and it shows us that this is
the four pieces that make up
the garment shaping file.
All the tools that were grayed out because
we didn't have a shape open
are now available to us.
First, before we get to the icons,
if I click on my piece with my left mouse
button, it becomes the active
piece which is white.
If I use my right mouse button,
I can drag these pieces into a position
that I would like and I can still
see all of my garment piece.
This is a sleeve.
It has a vertical mirror on it,
which means that things that happen
on this side also happen
on this side as a mirror.
If I click on this as the active point,
it puts a little square around it in green
to remind you it's the active point.
Let's put it way out here and you can see
that it has changed this side, but it has
also matched the changes on this side.
Let's say undo.
I can turn my vertical mirror
on and off using this icon here.
Vertical and horizontal mirrors.
Turn this off and let's go
to the front of the garment.
The next icon over is centralized piece
and this makes the current active piece
the largest that it possibly
can in the workspace.
Centralize all is next and this lets you
see all of the pattern pieces
that comprise the garment shaping
file at one time on the screen.
Let's go back to centralized piece.
This big cursor here makes
a very large cursor.
I can come down here to the bottom.
There we go.
I can come down to the bottom and it turns
red when it is exactly lined up with that
particular part of the garment piece.
If you look all the way over to the right,
it says that it's 0 bottom.
I'd have to move over a little bit more.
It says it's zero for the bottom.
This means that this is the point
of origin and we'll get
into this in another tutorial.
The next icon we want to turn big cursor
off and we want to turn the point
numbering on these numbers are the numbers
that define the shape
of this garment piece.
The numbering convention is
that the numbers start at point number one
at the highest point and the
leftmost point of the garment.
So we have two of the highest one,
but this one becomes point number
one because it's to the left.
If I click on point number eight and move
it up, it now is the highest point,
and it becomes .1, and it numbers it all
the way around the garment clockwise.
Let's say undo this.
I can use the undo button up to 20 times
instead of only once that we
had in designaknit it seven.
So this means that I can walk back
for a mistake or I can roll it
back to revert it here, too.
So if you change your mind
about your shaping it's okay.
Now there's a folder here
which brings up shaping thumbnails.
This is new to designaknit it.
I'm going to save this.
This is new to designaknit an eight.
Before, you can only see stitch patterns,
but now you can see the parts
of the thumbnails as well.
This is a baby sweater.
This is a baby cardigan.
This is a child's top that we're
working on right now.
The dark blue backgrounds means that these
are standard garment styling shapes.
You can see that they are put together
and gray for the garment pieces.
The ones like this with the very light
gray background and blue garment piece,
means that I'm in original pattern
drafting because it's light gray.
And these pieces were created
in original pattern drafting.
They were never standard
garment styling pieces.
This one here is a medium blue,
and I have four garment pieces.
This is the child's top that we're working
on that originated from standard garment
styling section and are now
in original pattern drafting.
This waistcoat here is the same.
It's an original pattern drafting,
but it has a standard garment styling
piece and also two pieces that are
originated in original pattern drafting.
This last piece over here shows the front
panel and one of the back panels
in standard garment styling
section of the program.
And it shows other pieces that are
in blue, medium blue, that say that these
originated in original pattern drafting.
We have a third kind of piece which is
exact stitch layout piece
and is shown in green.
And we'll talk about this
in a different tutorial.
I can use my sort button,
and if you have a lot of pieces,
you can easily sort them by age group
and by garment type, et cetera.
I have a search button
which allows me to search for, let's say,
just children, just adults, females,
males, sweaters, number of pattern pieces,
text in your notes, in your
tension and notes filed and the last
date that it was saved.
Okay, magnifying glasses.
Zoom out so that you can
see more shaping files.
And this one zooms in so that you can
see the shaping files closest to you.